noch ist der baustopp
[Musik]
wieso
ok
was ist es das ist einberufungsbefehl
was machst du da ich bin ja kommandant
der zweiten jäger komponiere körper am
boden und am 4 5
wirklich ein in den assistenzeinsatz zum
küchen für drei monate also sondern
experten was die bundesminister bei der
pressekonferenz für drei monate über das
ist der insight
[Musik]
drei monate die jungs der unbedingt
helfen weil die ganze anschauen um die
die schwester christa nur da wo sie ist
aber die brauchen dringend und das ist
das ist so wichtig dass wirklich wollten
der sommer und das oft drei monate
ok dann geht es schon am boden
was damals zusammen gelegt hatte
[Musik]
aber immer wenn es möglich ist
wir haben und wenn ich daheim bin
nun doch nicht die 2000 jungs fragen
werden dabei helfen mit dem klaren ja
und ja und sich aktionen unterschied zu
dem hause
die was sie geleistet denn die brauchen
deswegen habe zwar gesagt aber sie
schaffen und besuchen heute zusammen
[Musik]